- I heard that you enjoy
something called shower wine?
What is this?
- It's wine one drinks in the shower.
(Kelly laughing)
Yeah.
It's a good old fashioned shower wine.
- [Kelly] I like beths wine.
- [Rachel] Yeah, great. It's like-
- Oh my God. You're full one in a shower,
just like, yeah.
- Yeah. You have a hard day.
- I'm gonna try this.
- It's a way to have,
it's a way to have it all.
It's a way to have all
the things all at once.
You have a nice warm shower,
you like put on some tunes,
just bring your glass in with you
so that you can have all
the relaxation at once
- 'Cause it's such a great thing.
People for-
- It's nice.
- A shower is amazing.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if you've
ever been camping,
but I was camping for a minute one time
and we didn't shower for a while
and I was like,
(Kelly gasping)
oh!
Like just steam. Yeah.
- It's all over your body
all at the same time.
Love a bath too.
But you know yeah, exactly.
There's steam-
- Wine in the shower.
- Yeah. Shower wine.
- I like your style.
- Yeah.
- Little table for it
in there. Okay, okay.
Do you have any other-
- Especially,
yeah, if you have like a little,
I don't know, you can put it on anything,
you know, a turned over planter
or if you have it bench
or just on the floor.
- 'Cause you're like,
that plant died.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I didn't properly take care
of that.
- I couldn't keep that alive
so it's my shower wine stand now.
- I love it.
- Me.
- Totally happened to me.
I try and keep them alive.
But do you have any
other beverage fixations?
'Cause I'm obsessed with coffee and tea.
- Just general?
- Obsessed.
- All coffee and tea?
- I love the ritual of it.
I love all of it.
- What kind of tea?
What kind of coffee?
- All kinds.
Like I will do decaf, caf.
It depends on the type of day.
I love tea.
Like I have my only thing that steeps it
for the amount of time.
Like I love caffeinated, I
love herbal, I love everything.
- [Rachel] So you like the ritual?
Is there like a time of day that you-
- Any time of day.
- Any time. Anywhere.
- Yeah. It's probably why I'm like-
- All coffee, all day.
(Kelly ringing)
- All the time.
- [Rachel] I understand.
- It's probably why they say
I'm your character.
(women laughing)
- It takes a lot of coffee.
- I'm a lot.
- No tea, only coffee
to keep that one going.
- Oh my God. I love both.
Do you?
- I also, I do and I also,
this is a very unpopular opinion,
so I'm just-
- I can't wait.
- I'm trying not to get canceled
on Kelly Clarkson this morning,
but
I love gas station coffee.
- I think it's a-
- Like on a road trip?
Like if that's the option?
- Like always. Like-
- Like, that's your pick.
- I mean,
that's not where I would go every day,
but I do love,
I think it it's a nostalgic thing.
You said camping.
I grew up camping a lot
and you know you're out in the woods
and there's nothing
better than instant coffee
in the morning.
- Oh the my gosh.
- You know, you pour
it in, it wakes you up.
And just you're out in nature
and it feels so good.
- Just warm.
- I think it's a remnant of that.
It's like when you entered civilization
there was always a gas station
or when you feel like flat getting off a-
- They always have all the fixings too.
- Yeah. Getting off a plane-
- Like if you want some creamer.
- Coffee-Mate.
- Yeah.
- The most basic thing about me.
Love vanilla Coffee-Mate.
- Most basic thing about me.
That's awesome.
- Yeah, yeah.
Vanilla Coffee-Mate.
- I love that.
- That gas station coffee.
- Catch you in a Seven-Eleven,
just throwing down on some caffeine.
- That's right.